Before we go, we wanna give an extra special shout out
to none other than Jason Mamoa and the team Mananalu Water.
They're working hard to end single use plastics.
And they're hooking us up with aluminum canned water
all season long for our crew and audience.
That's right, Mananalu was the official water
for season one and it is there for season two as well.
We love you, Jason Mamoa.
Yes, Jason Mamoa.
(audience applauds)
I love his water,
but I have to say Jason Mamoa,
you should be making Jason mimosas.
I just wanna put that out there.
(audience laughs)
I just wanna say I love you,
and I love that you're making the world a better place.
Thanks to everyone for being here today.
And thank you to anybody who might be watching at home
or on the go.
We're so honored that you spend time with us,
hydration station, come back soon.
(bright upbeat music)